les soignants première victime du
comique 19 selon un rapport de l'eau et
metz entre 80000 et 180 milles soignants
sont décédés entre janvier 2001 et mai
2021 seuls deux professionnels de santé
sur cinq en moyenne sont pour l'instant
en vacciner dans le monde le directeur
de la ms dénonce une iniquité vaccinale
notamment par rapport au continent
africain et réclame une vaccination
prioritaire pour le corps médical
il est essentiel que les professionnels
de la santé soient vaccinés en priorité
les données de 119 pays suggèrent qu'en
moyenne deux professionnels de la santé
sur cinq dans le monde sont entièrement
vacciner en afrique - d'un professionnel
de la santé sur dix ont été entièrement
vacciner parallèlement dans la plupart
des pays à revenu élevé plus de 80 % des
agents de santé sont entièrement
vacciner
on continue d'en parler avec elle marie
pierre martin co présidente du collectif
intérieur jans bonjour merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors on vient de le
voir entre 80 et 180 mille décès de
professionnels de santé des estimations
qui sont réalistes selon vous
on a vu qu'en france y en avait beaucoup
dépassé déversèrent et de santé qui
était qu'avait été touché par le coup
vide après c'est aussi dit dans le sujet
on a une chance en france c'est d'avoir
l'accès au vaccin qui est assez simple
alors qu'on a des pays comme l'afrique
là c'est très bien dit ou en fait c'est
compliqué d'avoir accès aux vaccins sont
des vaccins qui coûte cher et c'est pour
ça aujourd'hui que le collectif s'est
aussi mobilisée pour la levée des
brevets des vaccins qui permettrait de
pouvoir démocratiser ces vaccins dans le
monde en fait on est dans une pandémie
mondiale et on a réellement besoin que
ce soit géré au niveau mondial et pas au
niveau local et chaque lit dans
l'hôpital dans lequel vous travaillez en
fait l'obligation vaccinale et 2001 pour
les soignants comment ça a été perçu
alors nous collections antérieures
jenson s'est positionné toujours de la
même manière
et pour la vaccination on est contre son
obligation n'est pour que les gens
puissent choisir après
c'est toujours des sujets qui sont
compliqués aujourd'hui l'hôpital il va
mal il va très très mal quand on voit la
situation d urgence c'est compliqué
quand on voit la situation à l'hôpital
quand on sait qu'il ya délit qui ferment
de partout parce qu'on manque de
personnel soignant on n'a pas les moyens
en fait de ce2 se permettre de de se
passer de ses collègues l'a alors
d'après vous trop peu de personnel de
santé ne sont pas encore assez vacciner
alors à l'heure actuelle que ce soit en
france ou dans le monde en tout cas dans
le monde c'est sûr ça c'est vous même
qui le dit si c'est un un soignant sur
deux dans le monde c'est pas assez mais
au fait c'est juste au delà des
soignants c'est juste dans le monde
entier y a pas assez de de personnes
vaccinées on a besoin que ses vaccins y
soit démocratisé pour s'en sortir
le chef de l' oms dénonçe l'inéquité
vaccinale et demandent aux pays
disposant de suffisamment de doses de
les partager alors qu'on constate que le
mécanisme international kovacs mme ne
fonctionne pas faute de vaccins
suffisant c'est assez paradoxal non
non mais c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on
répète depuis depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant voire même plusieurs mois il
ya plusieurs mobilisations il ya le
collectif stop brevets en france il ya
une mobilisation pour lisser e pour le
initiative citoyenne européenne pour
pouvoir lever les brevets en fait de ces
vaccins et des médicaments pour le coc
vide contre le coc vide et et pour aussi
avoir la réquisition des moyens de
production c'est quelque chose qui est
qui est faisable aujourd'hui mais la
france s'est positionné contre comment
on expliquer justement que les
gouvernements ne tiennent pas leurs
promesses concernant son système kovacs
moi je sais pas je sais pas comment
fonctionne ce système vous avez nous on
est là on est devant dans tout ce qu'on
voit c'est que la pandémie est l'heure
on ne s'en sortira pas si on est
uniquement au niveau local on a besoin
d'avoir une vision mondiale et nous tout
ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui c'est que
pandémie pas pandémie aujourd'hui on
voit bien que c'est la bronchiolite qui
met les hôpitaux en danger on a des
enfants qui combattent place pour être
hospitalisé on n'a pas de place en
réanimation pour les enfants on a des
soignants qui quittent l'hôpital en
masse on a daily qui sont fermés et
parce qu'on n'a pas assez de soignants
est en fait la réalité du terrain c'est
ça merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions marie pierre martin je
rappelle que vous êtes co présidente du
collège tif atteint l'urgence